c'est l'histoire d'un éternel
recommencement pointe lynche les algues
brunes ont fait un retour massif en
quelques heures à peine
dans la nuit de jeudi à vendredi à hier
matin quand nous sommes réveillés la
famille angoua de l'acquérir en plus de
sa grâce d'une voiture assez importante
au modèle 10 mètres de longueur la
hauteur
ça nous a peut-être ça le type et le
jardin de la nuit d'un mec alors ça me
fait penser à beaucoup de choses on est
un peu à sa voix panatois mois et puisqu
on voit cette fois qui arrivent
la convention état communes précise que
tout arrivages d'algues doit être
évacuée dans les 48 heures notamment
pour des raisons de santé publique
les riverains aimeraient bien y croire
ld aguak semblait pourtant que nous bon
ce à quoi on attend on pille on verra
mais on est un peu sceptique au début le
robbery exemple y danse
comment peut-on où elle a enlevé sa
quarante huit heures avec quel appareil
mais non cela laisse un peu bon la
priorité a été donnée à l'école de à
punta l'airé par rapport à l'école de
punta l'airé pour ne pas évacuer à
nouveau les enfants donc nous parle ici
là on espère que d'ici peu on viendra
enlever puisqu'il ya toute une cité et à
l'école de pointe
c'est une école primaire dans le
quartier une famille de pêcheurs a vu
les algues brunes arriver et c'est un
coup de main qu'ils ont disposé ce
grillage devant chez eux
sinon ça voulait c'était après c'est
compliqué les émanations de gaz tous
déjà le bateau le mojo et ensuite aussi
parfois nous apparaît ménagé ses mots
elle avoue santé une différence ou vous
imaginez qu'ils ont une différence pour
le moment ça va
pour le moment il ya une petite
différence mais bon
d'accord c'est pas parce qu'il ya
vraiment beaucoup qui descendent les
habitants de pointe un jeu ressentent
bien ce besoin de se protéger eux mêmes
dans le quartier trois familles ont dû
partir l'an dernier pour des raisons de
santé
asthme allergies la promesse de l'état
d'un ramassage rapide partait bien de ce
constat que l'on ne peut laisser une
population ainsi exposées aux émanations
toxiques